pari réussi pour sodexo cette année en
un mois et demi six mille trois cents
personnes ont participé à cette aventure
soit deux fois plus qu'en 2016 et au
final des résultats sont là on a déjà
battu un record en régions la région qui
a le plus collecté de denrées cette
année elle a collecté 8,7 stone c'est
énorme mais on a aussi battu le résultat
de l'année dernière cumuler avec toutes
les régions puisque cette année les
régions ont collecté 29 tonnes là où
l'année dernière elles en avaient
collecté 26 voilà quatre ans que
l'entreprise collecte des denrées
alimentaires pour les restos du coeur
ces produits vont prendre la direction
de l'entrepôt départemental des
clayes-sous-bois pour ensuite être
redistribués dans les trente centres des
restos du coeur
cette collecte aidera environ 15000
personnes un soutien précieux dans un
département où la pauvreté augmente
c'est un département plus affairée en
trompe-l'oeil effectivement l'image des
yvelines c'est plus une région protégée
verdoyant plutôt bourgeoise mais
néanmoins c'est le département qui
connaît la hausse la plus importante des
bénéficiaires de rsa
donc c'est pour ça que j'appelle c'est
un département en trompe l'oeil
il y à toute une précarité en fait qui
est basque et pour finir cette journée
une chaîne humaine est organisée entre
les collaborateurs de sodexo et les
bénévoles des restos du coeur
la collecte permettra d'aider les
personnes en difficulté pendant environ
deux mois